ladies and gentlemen Christopher Reeve
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you very much
[Music]
what you probably don't know is that I
left New York last September and I just
arrived here this morning
and I'm glad I did because I wouldn't
have missed this kind of welcome for the
world thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
when I was a kid my friends and I went
to the movies just for fun but then we
saw Kubrick's dr. Strangelove started as
thinking about the madness of nuclear
destruction Stanley Kramer's the Defiant
ones taught us about race relations and
we began to realize that films could
deal with social issues now when you
look at films like platoon in
Philadelphia Lorenzo's oil you realize
the power of film to present painful but
important issues to the public so here
are just a few more of the motion
pictures that have courageously put
social issues ahead of box-office
success they've enlightened us they've
challenged us and they've given us the
opportunity to learn